speaking of bozo bozo 969 mm you think I
mean he's definitely Boateng his [ __ ] he
saw how bad trolls did relative to
Goomba did it has like 11 million plays
no it does way on Spotify yeah it ate
[ __ ] it's like it's definitely not a hit
no but I mean damn really does
only 11 million what yeah I mean there's
been this conspiracy that not conspiracy
but I've heard you know that a lot of
artists bought their streams and [ __ ]
just to gas him up and make him seem big
hey um I I believe that six nine had
height before I definitely believe that
and that's why I think Fifi and bebe and
all that [ __ ] has like big streams but
yeah eleven million yeah a week is
nothing for him
zero Wow hmm I mean I haven't thought
about the song one time since I played
it the first when it came out
hmm I mean I it's not memorable to me at
all I just I just listened to part of it
and I was like what the [ __ ] even is
this this guy is he's done I just turned
it took a weird choice for a second
single in my opinion Oh bro I think he's
desperate the whole [ __ ] with him like
you know begging people to buy it on you
see that Instagram video of him begging
people to to buy the merch package and
to buy because he wants it to be number
one so bad it's just [ __ ] leader just
make the songs come out with them and if
they're good they'll speak for
themselves you have enough hype and
enough people will listen to it off the
jump that you don't have to do that [ __ ]
if it's an actually actually good song
yeah it's over for you
is done for that kid man he's I think
it's yeah I think it's out of there how
did you did you see
he has a song with Akon though coming
out oh yeah yeah yeah I saw that
what and then there was all this news
about I I just learned Akon owns a
diamond mind oh yeah he owns a lot of
[ __ ] he owns like he started some you
know he like brought power to certain
parts of what was it let me get the
story right Akon power yeah Akon
lighting Africa he started it in 2014
hmm so yeah it seemed he's investing a
ton in Africa but then owning a diamond
mind and he's like publicly said that he
doesn't believe blood diamonds are real
I don't know about that but I've seen
people openly I guess I don't know if
critical is the word but they they
questioned his his intentions some
people I've seen feel that he's doing
this but he's you know he's he's it's a
guise of philanthropy and really what
he's doing is just getting mega rich
which you know wild if true hmm wild if
true I can't speak to that [ __ ] but I
feel like 6-9 has exposed what we all
feel and he's fallen victim to it and
that is a guy making beats in his room
is just not cool every time foots on one
of those videos in this [ __ ] ankle
monitor and his suburban closet I always
feel like yaz is wack it's just gonna be
all like that's just gonna be his videos
now for this yeah the next foreseeable
future yeah this is not just him and
shipping his inner how many there's not
enough colors dude yeah you're out of
colors already yeah you used them all
what other color are you gonna go are
you gonna go - yeah also he's turning
into his ex-girlfriend yeah like they
look the same if [ __ ] crazy get with
the wig on and stuff like that yeah yeah
and all the shiny merch oh man Oh
bizarre yeah it's yeah it's bizarre Amy
oh man you know maybe um maybe this is a
real identity bro maybe underneath all
that screaming he's just he's trying to
hide a femininity that he's just he's so
desperately trying to get away from yeah
maybe this is all for Pride Month yeah
it may be all the UH
yeah I think you think he wakes up in
the mirror and and he puts on his blue
contacts and licks his lips and he's
like no no really
oh yeah those blue what is that a filter
what is that it's like a filter yeah
okay weird he's like it's like resisting
the urge to get on Grindr everyday yeah
and show off show off his blue eyes like
Nikon I'm not I'm not I'm not yeah hot
yeah yeah I'm six nine I'm the guy I'm
scum mosquitoes pack yeah I love
skittles that's what this all all this
is it's just I love skittles
yeah he's just looking for his skittles
brand deal but I mean if he if he stayed
on his career no actually I don't think
so I don't think skittles would have
went for it
yeah there's no way he's like the least
brandable person mm-hmm yeah
you